would you eat a steak grown in a
laboratory the technology is available
and we heard earlier that it could be a
boost to the economy as well as be a
boon to the climate producing
nutritional protein-rich food with what
the manufacturers say would be far fewer
emissions so kate to you first of all
should we welcome lab grown meat for
environmental reasons
i think it's a really interesting idea
and i think the government should be
supporting it do i think it is the
silver bullet that we need to tackle the
climate crisis no i do not i really
think that it could end up actually
being a bit of a distraction from the
things the very big things that we know
that we need to do and one of those
things of course is actually cutting the
amount of meat and dairy that we eat and
so this could help that goal but perhaps
what would be more effective is actually
strong targets and policy from the
government to reduce our meat production
and encouraging us to eat a bit less
meat and dairy as well as well as of
course supporting farmers to make sure
that they're growing the food that we
need and that their be their livelihoods
are supported and they're keeping us and
the planet healthy too okay stuart let's
pick up some of those points with you
and i also want to introduce one stat
here as well because our world in data
says that one kilo of beef emits 60
kilograms of greenhouse gases so
i i think i'm right in saying that you
do have cows don't you do you think that
we do have to look at alternatives to
beef for the sake of the planet
well i think this gets to the heart of
of the issue i think it's a really
interesting issue but one of the things
for me is we treat all meats exactly the
same we said we assume that meat is meat
is meat and what we know is that there
are very different emissions depending
on the production systems depending on
where it is produced in the world in
this country for example we have a
carbon footprint on our beef that is 50
lower than the global average and as
people start to
question more about their food where
their foods coming from as consumers
become more informed then actually i
think it's really important on all of us
to explain those different production
systems and the impacts both on uh
climate but on biodiversity and on water
there's sit behind those different
production systems okay what do you make
of that do you think it's fair to say
that we shouldn't demonize all meat
production and it depends on the way
it's produced
sure yeah i mean i think that
sorry stewart kate go ahead
i i think that that that of course is
really important uh but i think that we
can't actually get away from the fact
that emissions from livestock globally
are very high actually as a total of
greenhouse gases
agriculture is responsible for 10
of greenhouse gases in the uk and we
can't deny those facts and we do
actually need to
just appreciate we do have to reduce
all together across me and dairy okay
stuart just a quick response to that
then we can't deny the facts says kate
yeah look another fact that's really
important in terms of putting the uk in
context there's 278
million dairy animals around the world
producing dairy products if they were
all as efficient as a uk dairy cow we'd
only need 76 million that's how much
more efficient we already are in this
country and we want to get more
efficient we have a a target to get
agriculture to net zero by 2040 so by
looking at where food is produced how
it's produced people can make real
conscious decisions and and back
our production systems which are amongst
the most climate friendly
you